[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Pet grooming
combs are specifically
designed for animal fur.
They can get down to
the roots to detangle,
loosen, and remove dead hair.
A good grooming comb is
essential to the primping
process.
It's believed that the pets
of British and French nobility
were the first to be regularly
groomed centuries ago.
Today, a lot of pets
receive the royal treatment.
At this factory, pet
combs start with bundles
of long brass bars.
A computer-guided saw slices
them into 6-inch pieces.
Each piece will be
transformed into a comb body.
An employee inserts six of
the brass pieces into a vise
and tightens the clamps.
A computerized drill carves
dimples into the ends
of each of the blanks.
This is called a pre-drill.
The drill returns
to each dimple,
producing precisely-cut
holes to join
the combe body to a handle.
Next, a computerized drill
bores into the brass pieces,
creating small holes
for the comb's teeth.
The spacing of the
holes varies depending
on the type of comb being made.
Combs with tightly-spaced
teeth are used for finer fir.
The combs are now
ready for teeth.
An employee inserts three
comb bodies in a fixture,
then grabs a handful
of steel pins
and pops them into
the holes one by one.
These steel teeth aren't sharp.
They've been blunted
to avoid hurting
the animal during combing.
She gently taps the
steel teeth with a hammer
to force them further
into the holes.
She brushes off any
residual shavings
from the earlier drilling.
Then she places the
combs on a demagnetizer.
It erases any magnetic
fields in the steel teeth
that could compromise
the chrome plating
finish they will soon receive.
Next, a punch sets the steel
teeth in their final position.
At another station, a
device cuts extruded
aluminum into shorter pieces.
These pieces of aluminum
will be the pet comb handles.
Their contoured shape is
designed for easy gripping.
A worker clamps one of
the handles in a fixture.
It holds the handle
steady as he drills
rivet holes in both ends.
The fixture also helps
locate the holes through line
channels called bushings.
By drilling through
the bushings,
he produces accurate
rivet holes every time.
In the meantime,
the comb assembly
has been plated with a
rust-resistant nickel
and chrome finish.
It's ready to be
joined to the handle.
An employee aligns
the holes in the comb
with the holes in the handle
and places them in a riveter.
The tool flattens the
rivets against the handle
on both sides.
Then she dabs adhesive around
the open ends of the handle
and inserts plastic caps.
She hammers the caps down.
The glue sets quickly,
creating a strong seal.
After about a half hour of
work, this pet grooming comb
is now complete.
It should last for many years.
There will no doubt
be many tangles ahead.
But this comb will
pull through them.
And in the end, Fido will look
and feel a whole lot better.